comporting counted fraud i september's i
would heed i don't look very good I've
gotta change the white balance that's
better there's a little more color in my
skin the good thing about being a person
who only exists in videos is that you
don't have to go outside to get color
you can just change the white balance
now I'm extra orange and now I could go
out clubbing on the Jersey Shore
excellent John I have decided to follow
your and aim across Rosenthal's lead and
do some positive franking today I was
saying to myself what is the most common
form of prank the answer is of course
the prank call hey is your refrigerator
running okay you better go catch it but
I'm taking that idea and turning it
positive by Craig calling people with
encouraging and true facts about our
world
unfortunately Montana is one of the
twelve states in which you cannot record
a phone call unless all parties have
agreed to the recording so you're just
gonna get me just gotta get my side of
the conversation okay it's ringing and
answering machine I I guess I can use an
answering machine hi this is Hank green
of the vlogbrothers and I just wanted to
let you know that teen smoking teen
pregnancy and teen drug use have all
declined significantly since the late
1990s it's ringing hi this is Hank green
of the vlogbrothers and I just wanted to
let you know that cancer rates are
decreasing significantly year over year
no it's not just because of lung cancer
that's a really good point though lung
cancer is decreasing and that is part of
it but it's also because of increased
screening for precancerous lesions and
also the HPV vaccine yeah it's good news
I just wanted to let you know cuz it's
good news yeah okay bye that went really
well
I am surprised by how well that went
okay I'm gonna start telling people
facts and hanging up immediately because
I feel like that's more prank like than
talking to them hi this is Hank Ritu the
vlogbrothers and I just wanted to let
you know that global poverty rates have
dropped 30 percent since 1990 and
they're on track to drop another 10%
before 2015 to talking and I just hung
up on her ha ha pranked hi this is Hank
err to the vlogbrothers and I just
wanted to let you know the divorce rates
are actually much lower than people
generally assume 80% of people who got
married in the 1980s are still married
it's fun it's exhilarating hi I just
wanted to let you know that in the 1970s
they were only 400 breeding pairs of
bald eagles left but since the passage
of the Endangered Species Act that has
gone up to over 10,000 breeding pairs of
bald eagles Caiphas and sankirtan of
operatives and i just wanted to let you
know that violent crime rates have
dropped every year since 1970 and they
dropped 5% between 2008 and 2009 alone
so I have successfully positively
prank-called
10 people and that I think is a good
day's work I'm gonna put a transcript of
my script that I used for my positive
pranks down in the doobly-doo so that
you can make your own positive prank
calls because they are perfectly legal
to do though occasionally people seem
somewhat annoyed at me thank you to
people who follow me on Twitter for
suggesting most of these I didn't find
these on my own I asked people to find
me encouraging statistics about the
world and people were very kind and sent
some of these in and I genuinely hope
that the people who I positively pranked
today we'll think about the encouraging
fact that I told them about the world
and they will feel better about the
state of our planet and our society
because it's very easy to get
discouraged but I really think that
that's only because we get told the bad
news and we never get told the good news
and so I just wanted to tell some people
some good news today John I will see you
on Monday